?
>>> WELCOME TO "THE LEAD."
WE'LL GET TO THE MIDTERMS IN
JUST A MOMENT.
FIRST, A SIGNIFICANT STEP FOR
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND ITS
INVESTIGATION INTO THE JANUARY
6th ATTACK.
SOURCES TELL CNN THE DOJ IS
TRYING TO FORCE THE TESTIMONY OF
PAT CIPOLLONY AND PATRICK
PHILBIN, THE TOP TWO LAWYERS
FROM DONALD TRUMP'S WHITE HOUSE,
AND HEAR ABOUT THEIR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
THIS IS EXCLUSIVE NEW REPORTING,
SO LET'S GET RIGHT TO CNN'S
SARAH MURRAY.
THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO BREAK
THROUGH A FIREWALL OF SORTS
TRUMP HAS USED TO AVOID SCRUTINY
OF HIS OWN ACTIONS.
>> Reporter: THE FORMER
PRESIDENT HAS CITED
ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE TRYING
TO BAR THE TOP WITNESSES FROM
SHARING WITH CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATORS LOOKING TO THE
EVENTS SURROUNDING JANUARY 6th
FROM GETTING TOO CLOSE TO
CONVERSATIONS FOLKS MAY HAVE HAD
WITH THE FORMER PRESIDENT, THOSE
IN HIS INNER CIRCLE.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING TO COMPEL PAT
CIPOLLONE AND PHILBIN TO GET
CLOSER TO THE PRESIDENT.
THAT'S A COURT BATTLE PLAYING
OUT IN SECRET.
IT'S A SEALED PROCEEDING.
WE HAVE SEEN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAVE SOME SUCCESS IN
PIERCING THIS SORT OF PRIVILEGE
SHIELD WITH OTHER WITNESSES,
THOUGH.
SOURCES HAVE ALSO TOLD ME AND MY
COLLEAGUES, EVAN PEREZ AND
KAITLYN POLLANZ, TWO HAVE
ALREADY GONE IN AND TESTIFIED
BEFORE A GRAND JURY.
THEY WERE FACING SIMILAR
PRIVILEGE FIGHTS, AND A JUDGE
RULED THEY HAD TO GO BACK AND
ANSWER MORE QUESTIONS.
SO THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S
INVESTIGATION INTO JANUARY 6th.
WE, OF COURSE, REACHED OUT TO A
TRUMP SPOKESPERSON FOR COMMENT.
HE SLAMMED THE WEAPONIZED
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND CALLED
ALL THE INVESTIGATIONS
SURROUNDING THE FORMER PRESIDENT
WITCH-HUNTS.
>> SARA MURRAY, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THIS BRAND-NEW
REPORTING.
I WANT TO BRING IN ELLIOTT
WILLIAMS, CNN LEGAL ANALYST AND
FORMER FEDERAL PROSECUTOR.
WHAT DOES IT TAKE TO PIERCE A
PRIVILEGE LIKE THIS WHETHER IT
BE EXECUTIVE OR ATTORNEY/CLIENT
PRIVILEGE?
WHAT WOULD IT TAKE FOR A FEDERAL
JUDGE TO RULE THEY HAVE TO
TESTIFY?
>> YOU ARE RIGHT WITH THAT
QUESTION, JOHN.
ANY FORMER PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
BE ENTITLED TO SOME MEASURE OF
PROTECTION FOR CONVERSATIONS
THAT HAPPEN IN THE WHITE HOUSE
WITH ATTORNEYS EITHER VIA THE
ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE OR
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
NOW, LOOK, AS THIS HAS COME UP
OVER THE YEARS GOING BACK TO
RICHARD NIXON, IT'S VERY HARD
FOR A WHITE HOUSE TO OVERCOME
THE CRIMINAL PROCESS.
AND IF CRIMINAL INVESTIGATORS
ARE LOOKING INTO SOMETHING AND
BELIEVE THERE MIGHT BE EVIDENCE
OF A CRIME SOMEWHERE, THEY CAN
PIERCE THOSE PRIVILEGES AND THAT
MAY HAPPEN HERE.
>> EVIDENCE OF A POSSIBLE CRIME.
WHAT THEN DO YOU THINK IT IS
THAT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
THAT INVESTIGATORS WANT TO GET
AT?
WHAT DOOR COULD BE OPENED WITH
THE TESTIMONY OF PHILBIN AND
CIPOLLONE?
>> NOW, LOOK, IF IT'S RELATED TO
JANUARY 6th, MY ASSUMPTION IS
THAT IT MIGHT BE TIED TO THE
FALSE ELECTOR SCHEME WE'VE HEARD
MUCH ABOUT WHICH IS
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE WHITE
HOUSE AND INDIVIDUALS AROUND THE
COUNTRY AS THEY WERE SEEKING TO
UNDERMINE THE RESULTS OF THE
2020 ELECTION.
THAT'S A GUESS HERE.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW.
AS SARA'S REPORTING NOTED, THIS
IS HAPPENING IN SECRET, SEALED
PROCEEDINGS BECAUSE OF THE
SENSITIVITY OF THEM, BUT, LOOK,
ANY NUMBER OF MATTERS WOULD HAVE
COME THROUGH THE WHITE HOUSE,
AND CERTAINLY YOU AND I ARE BOTH
WELL AWARE OF THE NUMBER OF
INVESTIGATIONS SURROUNDING THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
SO AT THIS POINT WHO KNOWS?
>> CIPOLLONE DID SPEAK TO THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE, ALTHOUGH
IT WAS IN SPECIFIC AREAS WITH
PARAMETERS.
PRESUMABLY THERE WOULDN'T BE THE
SAME PARAMETERS HERE.
I WANT TO MAKE THIS
UNDERSTANDABLE FOR OUR AUDIENCE,
LIKE ME, DON'T HAVE LAW DEGREES.
THE ISSUE HERE IS WHAT?
IF PROSECUTORS CAN PROVE TO THE
JUDGE, IF THEY CAN MAKE THE
JUDGE DETERMINE THAT PAT PHILBIN
IS A WITNESS TO POSSIBLE CRIMES,
I GUESS THE STANDARD WILL BE
MORE LIKELY THAN NOT THAT CRIMES
WERE COMMITTED, IF HE WAS A
CRIME TO -- A WITNESS TO SUCH
CRIMES, THEN THAT TESTIMONY
COULD BE COMPELLED?
>> YES, IT CERTAINLY COULD BE
COMPELLED.
NOW, LOOK, ANY ADVICE HE'S
PROVIDING TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IN HIS CAPACITY AS A
LAWYER IS GOING TO BE PROTECTED.
BUT THERE'S A WORLD OF MATERIALS
THAT MIGHT HAVE HAPPENED OUTSIDE
OF THAT SCOPE IF HE'S NOT
ADVISING ON THE LAW AND MERELY
SEEING CRIMES HAPPEN, IS A PARTY
TO A CRIME HIMSELF -- WE DON'T
HAVE EVIDENCE IF THAT'S
HAPPENING -- IF HE'S AWARE OF
SOMEONE ELSE'S KNOWLEDGE OF
CRIMES, ALL OF THOSE ARE FAIR
GAME.
ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE OR
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE, ARE THE
COMMUNICATIONS THEMSELVES IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE PERSON'S JOB.
BUT THAT'S NOT GOING TO PROTECT
LAW BREAKING IF, IN FACT THAT
DID HAPPEN.
>> MARK SHORE, CHIEF OF STAFF TO
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE AND
JACOB, HIMSELF A LAWYER, THE
FACT THEY HAVE ALREADY TESTIFIED
THROUGH WHATEVER LEGAL PROCESS,
THE FACT THEY DID, IS THAT A
PRECEDENT THAT WILL PLAY HERE?
>> OH, ABSOLUTELY.
PATRICK PHILBIN, A SENIOR
ATTORNEY IN THE WHITE HOUSE AS
WELL.
FRANKLY THAT -- I MADE A
REFERENCE TO NIXON BEFORE, AND
THE EFFORTS THAT WERE USED TO
PIERCE SOME OF THESE
ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE
QUESTIONS.
THE MERE FACT THAT WE HAVE --
THE NATION HAS SEEN TESTIMONY
FROM SENIOR WHITE HOUSE STAFFERS
AND SENIOR LAWYERS WILL
ABSOLUTELY BE IN THE MIND OF THE
COURT THAT IS CONSIDERING
WHETHER IT IS APPROPRIATE TO
BREAK OR PIERCE THESE
PRIVILEGES.